la manifestación aquí en París se
terminó sobre todo con muchos disturbios
entre jóvenes encapuchados y en las
fuerzas del orden la policía que
respondió con gases a lacrimógenos y
también muchas canecas que fueron
incendiadas más con todo el problema que
hay de basuras en estos momentos con la
huelga de quienes recogen a la basura en
la ciudad pues esto incrementó aún más
todos estos disturbios vimos algunos
jóvenes que fueron arrestados por la
policía policías también que tuvieron
que ser evacuados porque resultaron
heridos En todo caso aquí para llegar a
la Plaza de la ópera de la que estamos
cerca solamente dos calles pues se
presentaron todos estos disturbios pero
lo que hay que tener en cuenta del día
de hoy es la fuerte participación de los
franceses cerca de 800,000 personas
marcharon aquí en París esto según las
cifras de los sindicatos demostrando que
los franceses no se dan por vencidos a
pesar de que la reforma pensional ya
haya sido adoptada por la asamblea
nacional ahora los manifestantes
continúan pidiendo que retirada esta
reforma a pesar de un gobierno que una
vez más se mostró inflexible después de
esa intervención en la en la televisión
por parte de Manuela este miércoles los
franceses continúan entonces en las
calles están de acuerdo en que el
movimiento esté mucho más radicalizado
de que haya continúen a las huelgas en
todo el país y en todo caso quieren ya
que se retire esa reforma que no entra
en vigor como lo quiere el gobierno y
también piden que Elizabeth pues Deje su
cargo En todo caso qué es lo que queda
por ahora en medio de este pulso entre
la calle y el gobierno pues queda la
opción de esperar que va a decir el
consejo constitucional que tiene que
examinar el texto de esta reforma
pensional y luego también está la opción
de ser referendo que muchos aquí entre
los manifestantes apoyan se necesitan
unos cuatro millones de firmas para que
este pueda finalmente ser aprobado Y
entonces sean los franceses quienes
decidan si quieren o no Esa reforma
pensional